s
policières la même journée ont
forcé le confinement dans deux
Jean-sur-Richelieu, heureusement
c c c conséquence, et ensuite,
au collège Montmorency, à Laval,
où quatre personnes ont étéseset
produite à l'extérieur
de l'établissement en début
de soirée. Hadnfnfnfnfnfnfnfnfns
que les élèves sont confinés à
l'intérieur du col
Montmorency. Tout a commencé
vers 17h30. Des coups de feu ont
été entendu.
blessées ont été aperçu etlololr
qui s'est rendu ici sur le
terraiolololollège Montmorency.
La f
l'intérieur de l'école, mais
plutôt à l'extérieur à
personnes atteintes par balles
qui pour se réfugier ont trouvé
refuge dans le collège.
Voilà pourquoi ça a créé ce vent
de panique sur le campus du
parents qui étaient là au cours
dizaines, voire par centaines,
qui se sont rendus sur les
lieux, inquiets en apprenant
cette affaire. Les parents qui
ont été rassurés par les
policiers. Le défi aura été le
suivant : dire aux parents que
l'intérieur de l'école.
Mais on ne prend aucune chance,
chaque recoin. Je vous laisse
entendre quelques parents.
- C'est ma fille q
- Est-ce que vous avez réussi
à lui parler r?r?r?r?
- Oui, par texto on s'est parlé,
elle me dit qu'elle est bien.
- Je n'atrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtt
- Vous vous sentez comment
ce soir?
- Je suis super anxieuse,
j'ai juste hâte qu'ils sortent.
Je ne sais pas ce qui se p
choses qui se sont passées,
mais est-ce que c'est ntntntnt
ça? On ne le sait pas.
ololololice est toujours à la
recherche de l'auteur de la
- Exactement. On ignore
l'identité des victimes tout
comme les motifs qui ont conduit
à cette fusillade. On n'a
identifié deux suspects. Ont
contré au moins un suspect selon
les policiers sont nombreux sur
le terrain.
GENEVIÈVE MAJOR
Service de police de Laval
de faire des vérifications
à l'intérieur du Collège
Montmorency. C'est pour ça que
par mesure de précaution, on a
demandé aux élèves de rester
Il faut comprendre qu'il faut
éviter le plus possible de
mouvements et de contamination
de la scène. Évidemment qu'on
demande aux citoyens du secteur,
qui est armé ou un individu
qui est louche, qui se trouv
dans leur cours, bien de
ne pas hésiter à faire le 911
puis de nous contacter.
de déployer son poste de
commandement sur le terrain de
l'école, qui se trouve à
l'arrière de la façade
principale. Une enquête qui ne
fait que commenc